so while the main part of the UN General
Assembly gets underway later on Tuesday
some key meetings have already taken
place
on the sidelines like talks between the
five signatories in the Iran bill as a
result at the European Union's foreign
policy chief said the bloc will continue
to trade with Iran and make sure
financial links are maintained the move
does come in defiance of the US which
quit the deal with Iran and reimpose
sanctions arteezy
alia petrenko now reports from new york
with the very important people arriving
in town it is time to get things sorted
just a couple of hours after Sergey
Lavrov landed in New York he was sitting
behind closed doors with the ministers
representing the international players
who once made the Iran nuclear deal
possible that's the one Donald Trump
called garbage but II used top diplomat
federica mogherini late on Monday came
out and said that Iran is fully
complying with all the terms of the deal
so everyone besides Washington will keep
supporting it plus Europe will protect
its businesses that are keen on dealing
with Tehran and here's what they came up
with for that mindful of the urgency and
the need for tangible results the
participants welcomed practical
proposals to maintain and develop
payment channels notably the initiative
to establish a special purpose vehicle
to facilitate payments related to Iran's
exports including oil and imports which
will assist and reassure economic
operators pursuing legitimate business
with Iran
we'll keep hearing the word Iran loads
and loads of times later this week this
is how big the
is at this year's General Assembly at a
UN Security Council session devoted to
the Iranian issue Donald Trump will
replace his diplomats at the table to
defend his cause we see presidents do
that on very special occasions to say
the least in the meantime America's
national security adviser and the
number-one diplomat are trying to make
their contribution to sorting out the
Iranian nuclear issue by opening a
summit called United against nuclear
Iran
[Music]
perhaps you wouldn't really expect
people taking part in these kind of
events to really be willing to sit at
one table with Iranian officials however
this is what Mike Pompeo said not so
long ago the president has been pretty
clear about that he's happy to talk with
folks at any time so what will happen
next to how the administration in
Washington is treating Iran and will any
of the international players be able to
affect it we will find out in the next
few days all right so let's dig further
into this story I live now for Colin
cavil the associate producer of
political science at Bluefield State
University joining us now from Bluefield
West Virginia calling great to see you I
know it's late where you are so thanks
for joining us here on Rt how do you
think our Washington will react to the
--use plan to continue trading with Iran
and ultimately circumvent US sanctions
mr. Roy the Trump administration will
see the European stance as a direct
opposition to the president Trump's
threats President Trump has told the
European countries and any country in
the world that deals with Iran after
November 1 that they will be directly
targeted so by standing up to the u.s.
France Germany Italy the big III
countries plus China and Russia and Iran
he will see this as a threat and he will
condemn them this week when he goes to
the United Nations they have been trying
to undermine
in fact we just saw Rudolph Guiliani
the advisor to President Trump he's more
like a conciliator of the Mafia and he
is talking about how glad he is and how
gleeful he is by the number of attacks
going on in Iran and the undermining of
the government so this is the purpose of
the United States right now is to
undermine the government of Iran and to
severely attack it as well as anybody
else who trades oil natural gas with
Iran so this is part and parcel of a
larger plan that is going on the
confrontation between the u.s. Saudi
Arabia and its allies and Russia China
Iran and its allies so this is setting
the stage for a much larger conflict mr.
Rory
all right we're calling we're gonna get
further into into the story in just a
moment I did want to ask you though
first eg do you think the EU is making
the right decision here favoring the
preservation of the nuclear deal and of
course oil exports and imports with Iran
over strong relations with Washington
well if they want to maintain any
semblance of respect any sort of
independence any sort of sovereignty
then they will have to stand up they
will have to stand up in order to be
counted to be dictated to by the United
States and just abide by whatever the US
says and be at the United States
beck-and-call means that you really have
no sovereignty and
detriment so if they're going to have a
say in what goes on in modern
international relations then they have
to stand up and make their stand count
and that means standing up to the US
when it says that they can't do what
sovereign countries do and trade with
whomever they wish and on whatever terms
they wish so it is a big step for the
European Union it's a growing step
they've been for many decades now just
being the pawn of the United States and
now they have the chance to really stand
up to be counted
you